okay I have a challenge for you today
play along I want you to tell me whether
what I'm about to play for you is
evidence of Donald Trump lying which he
does often or is it evidence of Donald
Trump glitching badly and losing his
memory of what he said just minutes
earlier during yesterday's coronavirus
White House press briefing so let's take
a look at the evidence the new scapegoat
for the Trump administration around
coronavirus is the WH o the World Health
Organization we've seen this develop and
grow virally for lack of a better term
over the last 48 to 72 hours the Trump
administration has realized hey let's
just constantly say that everything bad
that happened is the fault of the w-h-o
now there's plenty of blame to go around
I've been critical of the w-h-o but the
Trump administration is going beyond
that and they are focusing their blame
singularly on the wh o while Trump
continues to insist he did everything
perfectly heated everything quickly he
had the best response of any country
obviously not true so let's get to the
video listen to what Trump says here
very very clearly he says we are going
to put a hold on the money that we send
to the w-h-o we are going to do that
very strongly it's going to be a very
powerful hold of the money listen to
Trump saying it coming out of his own
mouth World Health Organization because
they really are they called it wrong
they call it wrong they really they
missed the call they could have called
it months earlier they would have known
and they should have known and they
probably didn't know so we'll be looking
into that very carefully and we're gonna
put a hold on money spent to the w-h-o
we're gonna put a very powerful hold on
it okay so just so we're really clear
here this is just the sentence where
Trump says we are holding the money from
the wh o we are not sending the money
and we're going to put a hold on money
spent to the w-h-o we're gonna put a
very powerful hold on it so
we're all on the same page Trump says
we're putting a very powerful hold on
the money to the w-h-o a few minutes go
by a reporter says you know we're in the
middle of a pandemic is this really a
good time
to stop sending money to the w-h-o and
Trump says a hold who said anything
about a hold I never said that
this is minutes later ladies and
gentlemen take a listen so it's the time
to freeze funding to the WHL during a
pandemic I mean I'm not saying I'm going
to do it but we're going to look at it
you did say we give a commendeth no I
didn't I said we're gonna look at it
we're going to investigate it we're
gonna look at it but we will look at
ending funding yeah because you know
what they called it wrong and if you
look back over the years even there very
much everything seems to be very biased
toward China I never said that and
reporters incredulous start yelling yes
you did and he did one more time here is
what Donald Trump said just minutes
earlier and we're gonna put a hold on
money spent to the w-h-o we're gonna put
a very powerful hold on it and then
minutes later Donald Trump denying that
he ever said it so it's the time to
freeze funding to the WHL during a
pandemic we're gonna look at we're going
to investigate it we're gonna look at it
so you all know what my question is is
this evidence that Donald Trump's brain
function is so poor that he really has
no recollection that minutes earlier he
said we're putting a very powerful hold
on the money or is Trump simply lying is
he trying to rewrite history in real
time what explains this I want you to
let me know your thoughts I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman lying memory glitch
something else I don't know the answer
you let me know have you ever wanted to
learn to play the guitar but you've had
trouble committing to the time and money
required to actually take lessons I have
the perfect solution for you it's called
fender play
it's an app developed by the iconic
guitar company fender it lets you learn
to play your favorite songs in minutes
on your schedule with interactive video
lessons that are very easy to follow you
can use it for guitar bass or ukulele
I've been using fender play to learn the
ukulele I've gotten a lot better than I
thought I would in a couple of months I
had tried teaching myself using some
YouTube videos didn't really get
anywhere night and day difference since
I've started using fender play and they
have personalized learning paths that
will cater to your musical tastes you
can use it on your phone tablet or
computer and you learn at your own pace
which is just awesome one year of
membership gives you access to thousands
of lessons for less than the cost of one
traditional in-person lesson and when
you go to fender dot-com slash Pakman
you'll get to try it totally free for
two whole weeks free two week trial
don't lose out on that without any
commitment that's f en de are calm slash
Pakman PA que ma n fender dot-com slash
Pakman